didier raoult ne fait encore parler de
lui et cette fois ci ce n'est pas pour
le coc ville c'est une accusation très
grave qui vise l'équipe du professeur
didier raoult letellier h et de
marseille professeur et directeur à
liège suis méditerranéen fiction de
marseille depuis 2011 une enquête
interne est sorti récemment il
accuserait d'avoir mené des essais
cliniques irréguliers ou cinq sont ni à
juin un traitement contre la tuberculose
a été prescrit de façon illégale en tout
cas un autorisé par l' agence de
sécurité du médicament les
expérimentations sauvage et illégale
destinée à soigner des patients atteints
de tuberculose
quand on utilise des médicaments qui
sont pas efficaces non seulement prend
le risque de créer des résistances aux
médicaments déjà existants mais en plus
son réseau on prend le risque de
transmettre la maladie sauf que voilà
certains malades se serait plaint de
graves complications après la prise de
certains médicaments il va falloir bien
réfléchir sur aujourd'hui la la présence
à la tête d'heuliez a chu de province à
raul agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament a révélé que le parquet de
marseille avait été dessaisie du dossier
alors en quête compromettantes lancée
contre didier rahout risque si gros
et surtout on veut savoir voilà ce qui
s'est réellement passé et on a la chance
d'avoir le professeur raoul avec nous en
face time merci professeur raoult d'être
avec nous merci beaucoup bonjour bonsoir
merci d'être là en tout cas professeur
raoult c'est vrai qu'on a entendu plein
de choses on voudrait avoir voilà votre
avis sur tout ce qui se dit et votre
vérité parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
entendu plein de choses là ces derniers
jours fabrice di vizio était avec nous
thomas blachier également est ce que
vous êtes alors on vous accuse d'avoir
fait des essais contre la tuberculose
ali a chu
au sénégal c'est inexact
c'est il faut
remettre les choses en place
le les achètent à une fondation qui est
ritz des services de l'assistance unique
dans ses services de la licence unique
ya les médecins et c'est le médecin
prescrit des médicaments donc à chaque
fois qu'ils se prescrit un médicament à
chaque rôle des choses qui se passent
dans des services de l'assistance
publique c'est pas moi je fais beaucoup
de choses mais je m'occupe pas de
l'ensemble des malades qui sont traités
là dedans et en particulier je m'occupe
pas de tuer close mais je vais données
les données que j'ai récolté après cette
histoire qui me rappelle beaucoup un
livre de john kennedy toole tels que
vous trouverez ce que c'est si vous
regardez la littérature un petit peu
donc la tubercule
donc vous voyez ce cauchemar
alors
tuberculose pour expliquer ce
que sur d'autres tellement cocasse que
ça vaut le coup de remettre un peu les
choses bien sûr bien sûr tuberculose est
une maladie bactérienne le premier
médicament qui a été trouvé pour la
tuberculose c'est une famille çela diaz
il a qui est en pause qui a valu à son
inventeur qui s'appelle dommage que le
prix nobel forcément des loups verts
d'accord il est toujours efficace ce
médicament a una mm pour le traitement
des infections bactériennes sensible à
cet antibiotique donc bien entendu nous
à chaque fois qu'on a une tuberculose on
teste tous les antibiotiques est sûre ça
ne viendrait pas à l'idée de donner ce
médicament chez des gens je sais qu' on
a une bactérie résistante à ça
c'est un médicament très très connu
qu'un certain nombre d'effets
indésirables a plongé de 3 % des cas et
en particulier les effets indésirables
tila sont délicieuses c'est des choses
qui arrivent quand on utilise ce
médicament deuxièmement eux après hier
un certain nombre de médicaments
antituberculeux ont été découverts parmi
lesquels la clause à la clope agit ni d
laquelle est toujours traitée
l'ordinaire a toujours résidé pendant un
certain temps n'a plus été utilisé à
utiliser massivement commente il est
heureux c'est un médicament qui est très
efficace aussi bien entendu donc ont
prescrit ce médicament ils sont testés
et
qui est utilisé en particulier celles
utilisées chez les centaines de millions
personnes en traitement mahler et c'est
un des médicaments peut-être constituer
un lieu qui a le moins d'effets
secondaires 0 5% à peu près l'effet
secondaire est il là n'ont jamais été
constaté en revanche chez les
médicaments utilisés la notion d effets
secondaires bien qu'ils aient pu être
commandés est approuvé par l'asn dans
l'hymne est solide dont l'équipe qui
l'utilisé dans un était français a
rapporté qu'il y avait 50% des effets
secondaires donc des livres aux
pratiques sont des atteintes perdre aux
irréversible aisée la fin de reculer à
verser un produit très dangereux nous on
avait utilisé quelques années il ya
dizaine d'années ensemble en compte que
ça n'est évidemment extrêmement
dangereux on peut l'utiliser même le
traitement de base de tubercules aussi
elles arriveront piscine dans 5 % créer
des désespérés secondaires graves donc
voilà globalement le tabou des
antituberculeux qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement est elle deux phénomènes
qui se pose à nous est chère que l'eau
s'est tue encore un million de ou un
million six de personnes donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe claudia de
problème premièrement il ya les tue la
clause résistante en particulier à la
rifampicine et pour ses tubercules aux
instances ems a fait un certain nombre
de propositions
parmi ces propositions il y à celle
d'utiliser les médicaments qu'on les
utilise et la phase i
c'est sur le site de l'ol c'est pas très
compliqué à garder donc c'est un
médicament banal dans les tuberculoses
résistantes pour les tuberculoses qui
sont sensibles à reach en pis il ya des
questions qui sont codées très récemment
qui auraient été posés par
notre maître à tous pour la facture
serait un gros c était un parisien l'a
foutu dehors 65 ans aux états unis
travaillez pas encore 25 ans et qui a
montré que c'était le médicament qui
avait été le plus efficace de tout seul
chez à klaus et qui permettait de
résoudre quand même très importants cash
flows qui est la durée du traitement
très dur et du traitement actuel klaus
et six mois et avec la cocaïne il a
montré là aussi un financement
spécifique du halal l'institut de
recherche qui a publié un l'énergie nos
deux mondes qui montre que le peuple
fasse mine est le seul à stériliser
rapidement les animaux affectés mais là
c'est les animaux les modèles animaux
des animaux infectés par la tuberculose
donc on s'est posé la question nous de
savoir tuer puisque c'est le alors vous
pour la coface éminent à jouer la clause
résistant il ya eu poutine et les
personnes qui rentrent des cas que
publiées dans la littérature
nom de 13 ou 14 pays différents
et donc c'est le traitement qui marche
le mieux dans les cercles aux
résistances pour les sens ils ont imposé
un projet de recherche ce projet de
recherche a été d'abord accepter une
première fois par la scpp vers le comité
de protection des personnes
vous savez c'est le groupe des gens qui
regardent si on peut ou ne peut pas
utiliser un produit qui a donné un avis
favorable à nsn a donné ensuite un avis
défavorable il nous a surpris parce que
normalement l'année sam n'a pas à donner
son avis sur l'utilisation de
médicaments qui sont qui sont dans le
vidal qui sont des médicaments
utilisable dans un repositionnement et
ensuite on a redéposé ce projet ce
projet a reçu à nouveau un avis
favorable du cpp à nouveau l'année scène
sans explication nous a dit qu'elle
voulait pas le faire je vous rappelle
que pendant ce temps l autoriser un
projet avec le dise au lead qui donne 50
% d'effets secondaires donc en pratique
où on n'a pas mis en place dès qu'on a
eu de
la vie de l'année sème donc personne n'a
été l'objet d'année c'est un petit
depuis que la nes elle nous a donné son
ami les personnes en avant sont combien
les argentiers peut-être été dit et ça
c'est mon premier adverse
merci beaucoup de gens qui ont été
traités en tout et bien il y a ils sont
rentrés dans le service de maladies
infectieuses
il y a eu 113 personnes depuis que le
lieu a été ouvert
96 personnes étaient sensibles et ont
été traitées par les traitements
antituberculeux banale dont 13 sont
morts parce que malheureusement la
tuberculose tue il y en avait 2 13 qui
étaient résistants qui ont été traitées
par ce traitement est efficace pour la
résistance dont aucun n'est mort et il
ya eu ta patients qui ont été traités
non pas par notre protocole qui était un
raccourcissement thérapeutique mais un
protocole normal les utilisant ces
médicaments il ya eu quatre personnes
qui ont été traités comme ça parce que
l'on craignait la tuberculose ya
beaucoup de patients qui ont des débits
assez instable en réalité est qu'il pose
[Musique]
mais ce traitement il a eu plus de
chance de prendre ce traitement à tous
et est parmi ces cartes sont patients
qui ont été traités en tout il ya eu un
patient qui est mort d'un cancer
terminal avec art et soit donc en
pratique 117 sa comparution fait dire il
ya eu des traitements qui ont été
traités en fonction de ce que recommande
le lez et quatre malades qui ont été
traitées pour des décisions médicales
sur été prise parce qu'on pensait que
c'était la meilleure opportunité donc
professeur d'anglais vous nous avez vous
avez fait un résumé
juste donc vous répondez donc qu'on
n'avait jamais fait des essais sur la
tuberculose comme si voilà c'est donc
pour vous c'est une fête nous cette
histoire de traitement des essais
complètement irrégulier sur le
traitement contre la tuberculose sncf
etc nous d'accord c'est délirant vous
avez cm la base de tous les traitements
pour les maladies bactériennes c'est
quand vous avez le bac terry gou isolées
et/ou cette bactérie est sensible aux
antibiotiques que vous donnez at il
demandé les autorisations pour ça et
professeurs ont pas du tout non non les
autorisations qu'on demandait c'était
pour raccourcir d'accord mais ça on ne
peuvent donner un traitement six mois
mais pour donner un traitement de deux
mois pour voir s'il ya deux mois un
traitement qui était seul et ses
préjugés et donner du proviseur grosse
et on pouvait prêter de l'eau ce qui
change les pronostics de de centaines de
milliers de personnes alors j'ai de
toute manière c'est et c'est peu nous
voulons faire il essaie dans plein de
pays au monde actuellement nos rappelé
sur les chinois on aura les résultats
juste deux ou trois mois au fait soeur
juste pourquoi on vous accuse de cela
dans cette enquête qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on vous accuse de deux d'avoir fait
sécession belgique c'est complètement
faux qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui nous
donne enfin vous voyez lien stable si
vous voulez il y à il ya un vrai
problème dans ce pays il ya un vrai truc
que vous voyez pas vous négligez mais
qui est très troublant qui et comment
est ce que quelqu'un un médecin je pense
à accès en gare bien j'espère bien qu'il
a pu prendre des dossiers les
transmettre
ce sens germann en rompant la
confidentialité et des de ces choses qui
sont entièrement comprenez ça ça c'est
entièrement légal le recel par mediapart
de ces données totalement illégal et les
gens qui ont cru les dossiers de malades
pour essayer le matin vous essayez
d'atteindre son je ne vous dirai pas ce
que je pense c'est parce que j'évite
d'être en bourse y ait eu autant que
faire se peut c'est vous pensez savoir
de qui s'agit des donc laissez vous pour
chacun d'entre vous souciez vous la
question de savoir où ma zéro mort avec
ce traitement se disent pas on a zéro
innovations thérapeutiques sur la durée
si été notre question mais posez vous la
question si vous voudriez l élan d'un
hôpital dans lequel on peut fliquer
notre dossier et transmettre pour à la
presse ou un méga moi le jour il ya ça
fait 20 ans que je me dispute avec mes
collègues parce que je refuse de rendre
officiellement les sérologies pour le
sida parce que j'en sais que ces choses
arrivent et que je m'en méfie il faut
pas faire ça c'est pas bien c'est
rentrer toute la base du rapport entre
le médecin malade de dire écoutez pour
nuire à quelqu'un je transporte dossier
à la presse de manière plus
aiguë professeur donc vous aviez droit
de faire c'est essayer
encore une fois c'est cesser il n'ya pas
d'essai vin d'honneur il ya des choix
thérapeutiques qui ont été ses parents 5
qui avait des malades en phase 2 mois il
vient dernier je sais pas comment mais
on a eu 113 malades il ya des matches
qui sont passés dans l'hôpital et il ya
des matches qui ont su traitement
acquises à des bactéries sains et à
quatre malades qui ont reçu ce
traitement pour la durée du traitement
habituel la tuberculose qui sont tous
des mâles qui sont dans le village et
qui font partie des
médias
quand on dit au feutre on voulait dit
tout à l'heure qui a vu 13 morts de la
tuberculose quand on dit qu'il ya des
complications graves chez certains
patients cessé de ses treize patients
dont on parle dans l'anc est
globalement les patients ils sont morts
ont reçu le 13
malin et actes indécents civ ils ont su
le traitement normal tu veux une usine
en absolument pas reçu le traitement
dont nous parlons là le traitement par
lula il ya dix-sept personnes sinon au
sud malheureusement quand certains liens
et un arrêt thérapeutique dépit point
final là dedans il ya eu deux accidents
iatrogènes s'allier aux médicaments avec
quelqu'un qui a fait mi case sur le
traitement par agnès dean quelque chose
qui est connu et qui malheureusement
rives comme avec les autres traitements
et les implications et il va très bien
les choses 130
professeurs alors est ce que vous
risquez quelque chose avec ces
accusations est ce que il va y avoir une
enquête un petit bike fait ou pas du
tout parce que vous n'êtes pas du tout
travaillé et on verra bien moi je
souhaite qu'il y ait une enquête pour
savoir qui c'est qui a fait pris le
dossier de malades qui n'était pas
fait pour les transmettre à la presse
intégralement pour pouvoir faire quelque
chose dans lequel je ne vois même pas
comment à la fin je vais j'essaie chic
et comment personnellement je serais
concernés en quoi que ce soit donc des
gens se trompent de cible parce que je
ne vois pas on ne peut pas m'accuser de
tout ce qui se passe tous les médecins
font beaucoup de médecins tout ce qui
laisse à fond et tous les traitements
qui précède prescription et pour
défendre ta fait normale et banale donc
tout ça c'est une montée en neige que
voulez vous c'est de la malveillance
pure et simple pourquoi il suffit de
voir qui c'est qui réagit là dessus pour
savoir pourquoi il donne malveillance ou
les bougies pourquoi pourquoi on essaie
de vous abattre professeur à ou mais
vous monte au pam a marre de ce fait
sous les faire à part ne tiennent pas
j'espère n'arrivera pas on essaiera
d'amadouer qu'est ce que nous mettons
tous un tuyau simplement ce que les gens
faire mais vous vous avez accueilli je
pense mehsud est assez curieux il y
avait une enquête qui a été fait par les
gens de françois pinault le groupe de
lars eller qui a dû continuer dans
lequel on va trouver quelques uns de ses
recettes maintenant je veux mon
impression par mc leish directeur
général est venu dans l'intention de de
me nuire de ce nouveau directeur général
je sais pas fait ce qu'il veut et
matières ou simplement parce qu'il veut
je voulais lancer mais en tout cas tout
ça n'est pas sérieux c'est juste passé
donc tout ça c'est vraiment c'est que
des mensonges et professeur en
faisait face et que les affabulations
maladroit je je je je vous dise qu'il
n'ya pas d'essai en cours nous avons
essayé de demander les sephora poussière
le traitement cet été à ces refuges et
ça vous tous ses attaquants vrai on fait
ça ou vous dites encore on essayait de
m'abattre on essaie de trouver n'importe
quoi pour m'abattre et que cinq séries
monsieur c2c de tous dans du mauvais
donc je trouve que c'est tellement idiot
c'est tellement facile soul et on a les
17 dossiers non seulement je rêve je
réagis pas dans la minute ce comme ça
c'est pas moi qui ai beaucoup de gens je
vais les chercher dans vos nahles 17
dossiers sont là sont prêts ils sont
disponibles pour la justice et les seize
dossiers des gens au substrat tu mens et
puis si la justice a besoin des regards
des haies la bernoise et samaa et à tout
est expliqué dedans pourquoi les gens
étaient traités selon les des gens très
sérieux ce qui est intéressant de
l'homme c'est les imbéciles croient
toujours qu'ils sont plus malins que les
gens qui sont censés le métier c'est
rarement vous risquez quelque chose
professeur à où vous dites façon j'ai
rien à me reprocher il pourra rien
m'arriver c'est une enquête ces mêmes
c'est la même personne de quoi
voulez-vous qu'on m'accuse
donc pour vous il ya j'en parle à ce
sujet vous chez moi là pas dessus il
n'ya pas dessus pour moi à titre
personnel je vois pas quoi peut-être
qu'on va peser les quelques médecins qui
ont prescrit un traitement à des trois
manades qui n'avait pas été quitté par
existantes après avoir fait un conseil
entre eux je sais pas et ce n'est des
gens se trompent de cible ça m'ennuie
pour les gens parce que ça qui se
retrouve à devoir se justifier sur des
choses qui est juste le traitement mais
qu'est ce qui est juste de la
responsabilité les médecins professeurs
est donc vos réponses est ce que vous
vous réveiller tous les matins en semant
vous disons qu est-ce qui va encore me
tomber dessus qu'est ce qu'ils vont
sortir sur pc ça mais c'est ça cinq
cents oeuvres c'est
bien est ce qu'ils vont bien trouver
rien dans ma vidéo j'ai laissé ça de la
prochaine fois je vous dire que j'ai eu
la chance pour le bâtiment je sais pas
et ne le croyez pas non plus donc c'est
comme ça je dorme et j'attendais qu'une
certaine pendant dix heures mais qu'est
ce qu'ils vont bien pouvoir trouver pour
essayer de dire que non je ne fais pas
mon métier qui forcément se débarrasser
de moi le plus rapidement possible cela
de gentil directeur annoncé il ya
plusieurs mois dans le monde et comme il
est ce que vous avez fait en action en
justice le professeur ce que vous allez
faire une action dans steam vente
écoutez ses skis nier ce que j'espère
que manifestement le rockeur a été
saisie j'espère que les neiges d'antan
bas et que surtout il entendra ce qui
est je fasse gaffe et vous avez notre
division sa fille valeria ce que moi je
trouve c'est que de
30 le dossier de la transversale presse
pour que vous en servir lorsqu on
ventile parce que parfois je prends pas
trop comment les choses marchent ont
moins chatel
c'est tellement indigne c'est tellement
contre la loi c'est tellement une
alchimie compris bon mais également
parce qu'enfin recel de documents
confidentiels
donc je pense bâtissent et moi les
autres cibles en chine où le comique
comme dit bernard élie qui rend les gens
fous mais là on atteint le deuxième tour
nicky est intéressant la prochaine fois
je ne sais pas si on va m'accuser
évidente être d'être dans les foires
ouais leur a confiée l'elysée dans le
fond on a enfin donné de folie la
quinine
très bien